[Music]
it's finally here rocky iii opens today
anthony you'll get the tickets to rocky
iii before it gets sold out yeah i got
sunshine
your people have adopted rocky balboa as
their new god and
you're not here to see rocky are you
you're not made for rocky rocky's made
for guys like me
today is about you
and your relationship one and only oh my
god
tony hey do you remember we saw rocky
one together here with her down yeah
rocky always reminds me of you
journey
stay in rocky all right santa get out of
here
these are characters heroes who inspire
us to be courageous
i'm going to sophie sweet 16. tell her
happy birthday
tell her i love her
i remember like if it was yesterday
weird near tonight guys
everybody's going bananas he got so much
energy i don't know what to do with it
me too
what a movie huh
toughest always win
ah frank
you have the biggest heart wins
[Music]
we never think we're good enough we're
always getting pushed around because
we're afraid afraid of what people would
think what what they'd say i don't want
to be afraid anymore
is this not the greatest night of all
time
[Music]
you